hello everyone and welcome to a
wonderful game that was just played in
the chesable masters preliminaries it's
dingler and versus magnus carlsen and
it's one of those games that did not
live up to its fullest potential because
of the uh the the format it was played
in but then we always said that if the
format was different the position uh
that position would never have been
reached so uh you know it's uh it's a
give and take uh situation uh but uh you
guys will have a great opportunity here
to
improve on this game and make it even
even better as some of the
uh
some of the secrets were not revealed
during the game uh so let's dive
straight into it ding has the white
pieces and he opens with c4 he goes for
the english opening we have g6 by magnus
d4 knight to f6 knight to f3 and bishop
to g7 we transpose into the king's
indian defense we have e3 castles by
magnus bishop to e2 and b6 now preparing
to fianchetto the light square bishop as
well uh we have castles bishop to b7 and
now queen to c2 uh knight to c3 and
queen to c2 are both very very popular
here uh we have e6 by magnus and the
ding goes for the immediate b4 not
messing around obviously and uh magnus
uh seems to know this position very well
as he played a5 and tries to surprise
ding
right out of the opening because it's
only moved seven uh but ding already
played this position i was uh in march
this year you know dink had to play like
a hundred games to qualify for the
candidates tournament and he had this
position against shu where d6 was played
and this is in fact the strongest move
recommended by the engine but ding was
able to win this game however magnus
knows this obviously he plays a5 and he
says i've prepared for you well uh my
young apprentice so a5 it is as of move
eight that we have a completely new game
b5 being closes the queen side and now
only now d6 we have knight to c3 and
knight b to d7 uh we have a bishop to a3
and now rook to e8 you don't want a
position to open up while your rook is
still on f8 so rook to e8 rook 8 to d1
and now queen to e7 developing the queen
connecting the rooks looks a bit odd
placing the queen to
such a such a square that the bishop has
access to but magnus is saying there's
no way this position opens up anytime
soon and now comes rook f2e1
now uh the tricky move uh
uh was not a rook after e1 the tricky
move is actually knight to e5 uh we have
to take advantage of the queen being on
e7 as for the moment it it is a silly
square for the queen and our real goal
is to put a knight on c6 and then uh
well black would uh magnus will will
even uh either have to allow the knight
to remain on c6 or we're just gonna
put it on c6 the black will capture and
then ding will have a beautiful bishop
put
on on this diagonal so that's one way to
do it but okay it's a rapid game rook
after e1 and now uh magnus strikes in
the center with e5 and okay d captures
on e5 we have knight captures on e5 so
no no danger here uh knight to d5 now
attacking the queen here bishop captures
on d5c captures and now knight captures
on f3 bishop captures and now queen back
to d8 so what dean got out of this
position is that now magnus has a
backwards c7 pawn and that's going to be
a long-term weakness ding has full
control over the c6 square and if magnus
can or rather if dink can pile up on
that pawn uh it's gonna be great but
usually one weakness is not enough to
win the game you have to create more
weaknesses so ding starts with h4 he
wants to open up the position here play
g3 put the king on g2 and then put his
rooks on the h file that will soon open
up so this will be the second weakness
so knight to d7 by magnus he wants to
put the knight on c5 so he he closes up
the position that way dean will not be
able to
take advantage of the weak c7 pawn h5 we
have knight to c5 and now g3 uh well
like we said preparing king to g2 and
rook to h1 uh queen to f6 uh of course
magnus does not want to allow any sort
of an attack he wants to trade queens
right away king the g2 and now queen to
c3 and here ding does trade we have
queen captures bishop captures and now
rook to h1 the rook now uh occupies the
soon to be semi-open h file king to g7
and rook to c1 now chasing the bishop
back with bishop to e5 and now not
opening up with with captures and g6 but
rather h6 now we are no longer playing
an attacking game now we are in the end
game and we need as many
uh positional trumps as possible so now
we have we have uh this going for us so
the knight can never move from that
square and we also kind of boxed in the
black king a little bit here so king to
f8 and now rook to c for grabbing hold
of the of the entire fourth rank and now
uh what can magnus do we rook to e7
bishop to c1 now we have rook eight the
e8 and now pawn to e4 and here magnus
played bishop to f6 uh he attacks the e4
pawn three times now but the ding just
says you've got nothing here uh bishop
to e3 and uh there really is uh
no way for magnus to keep improving his
position okay the pawn can be captured
but then the c7 pawn will hang for
example if we just trade everything
captures captures and captures rook
captures on c7 then the bishop gobbles
up all of the points on the queen side
and then you just lose the game so
magnus says all right i admit it i've
got nothing here i'm just gonna repeat
moves with my king so king to g8 uh rook
to d1 by ding and now king to f8 we have
king to h3
king to g8 magnus continues repeating
and bishop to g2 now the problem and
pretty much the only problem for being
in this position is that he is very much
low on time uh he has some two minutes
on the clock whereas magnus is up to his
full 15 minutes on the clock he really
prepared well for ding as uh like i said
ding did play this game two months ago
uh so magnus knows all the ins and outs
of the position so king f8 bishop to f3
uh magnus just repeats he he uh he's
satisfied with the draw here of course
there's no way for him to push uh so
either ding will push and maybe over
push or he will settle for a draw so
king to g2 we have king to f8 now comes
king to f1 and king to g8 king bishop
back to g2 king of f8 by magnus f3 now
now we strengthen this pawn and now we
can activate our light square bishop as
well so this is one last attempt for
ding king the g8 bishop h3 we have king
to f8 king to g2 uh we have king to g8
king to f2 now comes king to f8 and the
bishop to f1 we have king the g8 and the
bishop to d3 so now ding is offering a
trade of knight for bishop but of course
magnus is not moving this knight away
from c5 the the c7 square will become
too weak so bishop to h8 and not bishop
to c2 and now uh with
all of this king bishop maneuvering
ding got very nice control over this
diagonal and this could uh come in very
handy as you'll see because here magnus
needs to just repeat moves he needs to
play king to f8 but somehow for some
reason this uh or this maneuvering by
ding i got magnus to open up the
position magnus played f5 and this is
now a completely winning position for
ding uh but uh
uh
there is simply not enough time on the
clock to figure this one out however you
are i hope very very comfortable in your
homes watching this maybe on your
smartphone or on your computer or laptop
uh so feel free to pause the video and
try to spot what magnus missed here uh
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on solving this one
and i really hope you you took your time
with this one because it's just
beautiful and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is bishop to
g5 but the first move of this uh tricky
variation is not the difficult one the
spot it's the second one that's
difficult so after rook to e5 and this
was played in the game now ding repeated
bishop to f4 but this is not the move
that we were looking for the true move
that you had to find after bishop g5 and
rook to e5 is e captures on f5 but this
seems like too much to give black
because now rook to e2 and it seems like
white might be in trouble but this is
exactly the line that we have to explore
uh because after rook t to check king to
f1 and rook to h2 now we want to play
rook to e2 and it doesn't seem like the
white king will be able to avoid all of
the checks however there is the very
forcing f capture sun g6 now rook to e2
g captures on h7 with check king to f7
now rook to f4 with check king the e8
and now the beautiful bishop g6 check
king to d7 and now bishop to f5 with
check kink the e8 and it seems like
white has nothing better other than
repeating moves here and claim a draw
but there is a bishop to h3 and this is
the move that uh
allows the whites to win the game and
this is of course the move that ding did
not have enough time to calculate
because who would see all of this but
now you've taken away the g2 square from
the black rooks and there is no
perpetual here of course if the bishop
is captured we're to gobble up the rook
and once once one check is given there
are no more checks and that's it now
white will just easily win the game so
what you would do after e captures an f5
is there's nothing better than g
captures on f5 and now we have this very
nice rook to d2 now we're saying okay
now there's no counter play and if you
look at the position there's really no
good move for black here black is
completely tied down for example rook to
f8 we
want to add more protection to the f f1
we're gonna play bishop back to e3
prepare the march over g pawn and after
something like a rook back to e7 we're
gonna play of course pawn to g4 now
we're just threatening to win a pawn
here so there are two options one is to
play bishop to f6 but this will not work
because after g5 the tactic that black
would have in mind rook captures on e3
it doesn't really work king captures
bishop captures on g5 with check hoping
to win back the material but not just f4
and after bishop captures an h6 this is
very much winning for white you have two
rooks and the bishop against the rook
bishop and knight and okay black is up
uh two pawns but the two rooks will will
more than compensate for that uh so
after g4 f capture sun g4 seems to be
your only option but now we have rook
captures with check king to f7 and now
bishop to g5 and this is with absolute
best defense from black what we would
get uh where absolutely everything loses
if we play bishop to f6 then we just
capture and after king captures rook
there for check notice that the g7
square is taken by the pawn so the king
has to move once the king moves we just
pick up the free rook and f8 and if you
don't go bishop
bishop to f6 you can play something like
okay rook is attack you can move the
rook back uh we just played bishop
captures on h7 and now there is uh
absolutely no square left for for the
black king this is covered by the pawn
this is covered by the bishop discovered
by the bishop by the bishop by the pawn
by the bishop
and the once rooked for checklands that
is just it so this is the position that
we could have had if this was um
well if this was a longer time control
but then again if it was longer time
control then we would never get this
position in the first place so that's
the kind of the uh the you know the the
beauty and the the horror of chess um uh
in modern times uh so here instead of e
captures an f5 that completely shatters
black's position being played bishop to
f4 rook f2 rook 5 to e7 bishop g5 and
here after a few repetitions the players
agree to a draw or rather it's a draw by
threefold repetition so really
i would say a ruined brilliancy uh
not not great but uh you know uh magnus
did prepare very well and he is magnus
carlsen of course dean doesn't think
that uh
magnus would miss something like this
and if he had maybe if he had like a
minute more on the clock or he had two
minutes on the clock so if he had any
inclination that there was something he
would start digging and two minutes for
ding it's like you know a week for for
the rest of us so i think he would crack
it it's just that he uh he didn't uh you
know uh his spidey sense wasn't tingling
so uh
you know so
that's the problem i think with this
game uh but yeah that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed it and that you were
able to solve this e captures on f5
mystery truly a truly a wonderful one
and then all the finding that bishop
all the way back to h3 that's just the
beauty uh so really hope you enjoyed
that uh i would like to thank david
kimura adam simmons robert kiefer and
mark manner and nagarjuna ponogoti for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it uh as usual
you can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing uh to check up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the chess world such as
games like these so thank you all i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day